hi junin hi fella hi
nice to see you
nice to see you too i had so much fun
watching a new era i was laughing i was
emotional i loved it
good morning
i'm so curious you know when you think
of that
first day on set season one episode one
could you ever imagine that it'd be six
seasons later two films later that we're
still telling this story
no
[Laughter]
okay next question no no no um
no i mean we wouldn't have dared imagine
would we that we'd be here for 12 years
okay i don't even think i can remember
the first day can you i remember
actually
yeah do you oh yeah i i remember that
first
scene that was certainly in it when at
one point
the house is taking you all around the
house yeah picking up different
characters and
daisy making a fire and i say to her
because she's taking forever and i say
you're you're building a
fire not inventing it
i guess it was better at the time
i've
um so so much of the comedy with this
film comes with the arrival of movie
stars of course in the last film you saw
the arrival of the royals so who do you
think is the harder guest to host the
royals or film stars
i would see the royals yeah i think the
royals i mean we hadn't we had royalty
in the film stars let's face it because
they were a royalty of a fashion but yes
no we had much more hard work yes as
downstairs staff as the staff yeah our
lives were yes and i think we're much
more anna and daisy especially are very
excited about uh the hollywood stars
coming and it's fun and um
you know uh laura haddock's character
character murna dale gleesh is from
humble beginnings and she's really been
quite um you know she's an icon of the
screen and so anna and daisy very much
connect with her because
um before they meet her because they
think oh she's a woman from a similar
background to us and look what she's
achieved so it's a real she's an
inspiration so i think there's a very
different sort of energy about about it
isn't that yeah and it's also yeah you
don't you don't feel that you have to
watch your pee and cues or be on your
best behavior because
well certainly from mrs hughes point of
view because they're only
you know movie stars yeah which you know
quite frankly mr carson thinks it's no
better than being on the streets yeah
it's so true there's always something
for stuff and i have to say my probably
my favorite scene in the film i was one
of the staff at dance and switch roles
got to be extras in the film i sit at
the dining table and and dress up what
was that like for you as actors finally
getting to really dress up
it was hilarious really i mean it's
funny that we should have
completely decided to step into the
shoes of the poor extras who weren't
getting paid we thought we'll never mind
them we'll take over
um but yeah no that that was great fun
to be all dolled up and dressed um
in those exquisite costumes by anna
robbins our wonderful designer
quite difficult to wear i have to say i
had about 16 bits to it and i felt that
i had a small family of
goats
i mean it was
[Music]
it was just bizarre
to wear
this is that what that noise was when
[Laughter]
when you're filming this movie with
modern technology how kind of cool was
it to see the way films were were
created back in the late 20s yeah it was
great fun wasn't it it was fascinating
yeah all the old equipment and and just
the trucks and stuff that they're the
old 1920s film trucks and the t-truck
outside craft services yeah i mean it
was that size but it was so cute and
original it was lovely actually really
nice very atmospheric very
yeah it did give the whole sense of
of being i mean it did give it glamour
actually to us didn't it as characters
it was real gram glamour to the people
working on it
you know like in life
you know in real life it wasn't terribly
glamorous for
mirna's character to be constantly you
know no such that but um
yeah no it was it was a it was a lovely
and quite
original way of of of introducing doubt
into the movies
and really adds to so much humor as well
in the in the film because obviously to
have you know iconic day maggie smith
double oscar when they're having all
these scathing lines about
actors and movie making and stuff just
really adds to the fun of it all yeah
okay i couldn't stop giggling so thank
you so much congratulations
thank you oh good thank you very much
you